hot breath what's amazing about your
comedy and
it's all well deserved how many times
you've been on tv and that you're
actually
your hour special's coming out this year
right yeah yeah on comedy central
is the stuff you get away with man
thanks man
is you you have figured out how to
walk the line like it's
it's a the topic maybe a little
off-putting like for like on your most
recent
conan set you're talking about like
sexual predators
right and how it's a tough you open up
by saying like it's a tough time to be
a predator right right now ty break the
ice yeah that's
my first the first thing i said in the
set is bad time to be a predator
yeah and you take it into like the
sports analogy like
how do you i mean how how do you even
evolve that joke into being ready for tv
from just something you say in a
clubhouse because i guess i'm so
fed up with the cutesy late night sets
where every every comic is trying to be
adorable
it just [__] annoys me because it
just doesn't
it's not genuine to me there's something
about it that's very
false and put on so
and then i guess maybe that's coupled
with the fact that
uh people don't want to laugh at a joke
just based on the subject like a word as
you said like predator it's like
that's like a hard joke to make funny in
that
you know given the constraints of a late
night set right so
to me that's like a challenge and it's
exciting it's like trying to fit it's
like almost like a math problem you're
like how do i crack this code to make
this work
and uh and the fact that people don't
want to laugh at a joke i feel like i've
i've won over someone that wouldn't have
either ordinarily liked my comedy i
don't like comedy that's like
just it's funny i was talking to a comic
about this the other night and he's a
you know very successful comic and he
said
you know it used to be that like people
go to the
middle of the country and
they persuade them to laugh at stuff
it'd be like they'd win them over and
now it seems that they're like
everyone has a brand uh as i look at
your water bottle
and uh no but it's like everyone has a
brand though and it's like
oh that's my guy and it's like i just
that's my guy but it used to be like you
kind of
you won them over and there's something
about that that is more exciting to me
than just
having the not that it's ever easy to
kill
i don't want to diminish people's you
know efforts in those sets but
there is a type of comedy that's a
little too
uh easy going for me and it doesn't
it does nothing for me it's like
it almost feels like they're kissing up
to the audience
and it's like no this isn't that's i
like it to be almost like a give and
take i like it to feel more like a
i like there to be awkward moments in
the set when i'm doing especially maybe
not a late night set but
when i'm doing a long set i want i did a
set in south by and there'd be
i got i bombed a pretty offensive joke
it was brand new i thought of it before
i went on stage i ran it by my friend
and he laughed
and i said i'll try it and it bombs so
hard
and i just [__] doubled down on it i
kept going further because i was like
what what the [__] do i have to lose so
a woman heckled me went back it was like
playful we went back and forth be like a
fun back and forth
and i maybe found something there and
it's like sometimes when you take that
risk and you bomb
you find something that's even richer
you know so maybe that's why the fact
that the
really agreeable premises that are
really obvious and like
i don't like comics going up there
saying i'm a nice guy that's a lot of
comics i see now i'm a really good guy
and it's like well wasn't aziz just
doing that
you know it's like so you're gonna it
just feels like anyone who goes up
who announces they're good is not good
to me that's just in my experience
anyone who's like i'm a really
trustworthy guy it's like
well now i don't trust you because
you're like
because all the guys i always like to
like they preface they were like look
i'm no
sane those are the people i trust not
the people that are like i'm a great guy
i'm i'm you know i'm rambling a little
here but the point is
the point the point is i guess uh
i did a joke right after the parkland
shooting
and it was uh about these people it
didn't hit it bombed pretty hard
in st louis i was in st louis that
weekend and i
said you know it's like these people
that believe in crisis actors you know
those
people who they think these kids aren't
real kids they think they were hired by
the
far left to be like actors and like
so i said does that mean they also
believe in like crisis actor agents
like there's some guy in the phone he's
like this girl is great she's been in
sandy hook she's been in
i mean you got she's going to be a star
you got to use it so i kind of
i kept doubling down on it and i kept
going further and it kept bombing
further and further
and i kind of like and it bombed so hard
that i kind of was like
to me it's funny though i know there's
something i feel like there's something
crackable there
and like i don't know i guess the comics
i always liked
in some way what do i have to gain if
it's just something we all agree on to
begin with if it's something we all
not that that should be your whole hour
because that would probably feel weighty
but if
if we're just saying like yeah this is
bad
shootings are bad it's like well no
[__] [__] dude i mean i see these
people writing like
like it's like they're virtue signaling
all the time their jokes are like
this needs to stop and i'm like this is
a [__] comedy club dude what you're
just announcing
like like you're some you know
like you're some political figure you
know like shootings need to stop we all
i i really get so sick of like the uh
like you know i did that joke tonight
about the baby getting eaten
by the alligator at disney yeah and it's
like
this that's basically what that woman in
the crowd was to me who got offended
where she was like
that's not okay and i'm like well
obviously i'm not [__] pro
babies getting eaten by alligators but
if if you don't like
dig for a joke there's i guess they're
just like well that's never funny i'm
like
well yeah to you but like other people
can find funny [__]
it's it's it's weird that like when it
when something's sensitive to someone in
particular they're like
i'm out i'm not laughing but
but they laughed the whole rest of the
show it's just you didn't like that one
thing
i was a comedian the whole [__] rest
of the show
and all of a sudden now it's not it's
not comedy anymore how do you know when
you're on to a joke because a lot of
times when you tell a joke
the first time and it bombs sometimes
you abandon them you're like oh never
mind and other times is there like if
somebody gets offended you're like okay
i'm on to something there because it's
no because i don't it's not it's not
it's not like i don't want the emotional
reaction always i just want like
i want something i want some reaction if
it's just i love a silly
joke i love like just a silly playing
joke dude i love watching gaffigan or
regan or those guys yeah but like
um i don't you know you're on just
because you know it
it's he's gonna get something it's gonna
get something some response like you can
feel
it it's like where i did a new joke
tonight they got something
it was it's not like a perfect joke but
there's something there about like the
queer eye guys about how they're like
you know
um about the firehouse they went to
but this isn't done yet but like the
idea about they were like
the firemen were all like you know we
weren't really okay with the gay guys
but then you know we got to know them
it's like you know they just gave you a
bunch of free [__] they gave you like
thousand dollars like that's not what
all gay men are like you know like
you're gonna be in for like a bad
awakening if
if uh if they're just like do you like
this guy matteo and like
i mean he's all right i didn't renovate
my kitchen you know but that's what they
that's what and like i felt a laugh
there so i was like there's something to
play with there it's not done but
there's like a premise to play with
and uh you just know you just feel like
there's something here
that feels but then also you know
there's some that bombs so hard you're
like well that may
never make it on stage again right it's
tough because they were so drunk early
on i couldn't really get a sense of like
silence of
where to uh pause the way i wanted to
you